All right, as promised, we're going to hop into Twinmotion
to take a look at how do seasons change.
It's kind of like the song,
but we're going to be playing with our environment
as it states and taking a look at some various types
of way of changing your environment
or the atmosphere ambiance is what we're going for.
So we're going to take a look right now.
This is just some of the things of the settings
that you can see up close
because it is a little smaller in Twinmotion,
but let's go ahead and hop right in.
So here we are in our lake house scene again,
and this could be any scene, obviously an indoor scene
that has no walls or windows, or rather no windows,
you would not be able to see anything
that's affected on the outside.
So this is more for when you have environments
that affect everything.
So let's take a look here.
So the first thing you do is come over here
and click on the ambiance
and you'll be able to see
all of these wonderful settings.
Now, if you do recall,
there is this little time of day as well,
and you can click on this little sunlight,
that'd be the time of day,
and you could adjust it this way.
And that's perfectly looking all right
if you wanted to do that.
Okay, kind of cool.
And we're going to kind of zoom over here
just to see some of the trees as well.
Let's kind of mess around with that.
This is a quick way of doing
that adjustment through time.
And you'll even see the moon move up there.
I don't know if you can see it up at the top,
but you can actually see the moon.
So now there are a lot of settings down here
that I want to kind of take a look at.
We won't spend too much time,
but you can replace the dynamic sky with an actual HDR.
So that's kind of helpful
if you're wanting a specific look of the sky.
But we can also change the time of day via this way,
and you'll see how it changes the shadows,
the direction of where it's coming from,
and so forth, and you'll see it goes into nighttime.
And again, you'll see that moon
kind of fly by a little bit as we go through here,
and you'll even see the stars.
Now it's important to note,
you'll see here that the lights that we added earlier,
you can now actually see them
and anything else that has lights or light affecting them.
So this is important to kind of keep in mind.
So if you want to see your lights
and make those adjustments as you're adding them,
you may want to adjust your time of day.
But again, let's go back here up into the ambiance,
which you just click here in the scene,
and we'll leave this,
we'll bring it back to let's say here
where it was at before.
So that's a little bit more time of day,
like maybe later in the afternoon,
you'll notice how dark it is here.
So this will give you a good idea
of where you need to place your lights
for a good nighttime scene.
But going down further, let's go ahead and collapse this
besides all of these adjustments you can make,
just kind of close that.
Location would be more if you were building this in,
let's say North Dakota or Michigan,
maybe off the lake or Ohio off the lake,
you could place it literally within there
and change the month as well.
So a lot of great settings.
Now the sky, the turbidity,
that's gonna be more of kind of like the haziness of it
from clear to hazy.
The more adjustment will add more particles to your sky
and can give it a little more of a discoloration,
like late summer, maybe you got some humidity
and you wanna add some of that density.
Then you can adjust even the details.
Now here's a star and moon intensity,
which you can adjust.
So you got a lot more moons, a much clearer sky,
you know, you could adjust that.
Then you also see these clouds.
Now we're not gonna get into
all the different types of clouds,
but there is a volumetric
and it's one of our newer adjustments.
Another thing, if you put your mouse over,
you're able to see some hints
that'll give you an idea what to do.
But now here is how you can adjust
like the cloudiness as well.
And you'll see like almost clear
to more types of clouds,
just various adjustments, kind of nice.
I like the clouds in there.
You can also come down here to your seasons
and let's say, let's look, let's make it rainy.
You know, I notice it kind of rains in a right now,
it's showing on the inside, we can fix that,
but let's just leave it there.
Now let's make it wintertime.
See what the lighthouse is gonna look like
in wintertime with some snow.
That's some really beautiful setup there.
And you can even have it to where the trees
are a little less, you'll notice out here, that tree.
I'll just move that around so you can see
the leaves will be gone.
So you can adjust that to different types of the weather.
And again, more details, you can open that up,
you can adjust the precipitants
as well as surface effects, the wetness, puddle size,
all sorts of great things, vegetation growth.
You can make it more, you can make it less,
all by a quick lever.
You can add some wind into here
to adjust how the leaves are being affected,
or the grass will move,
even the direction of where it's coming from.
Yes, you can even add fog.
So maybe you wanna increase the fog
cause it is kind of snowy and cold.
Yeah, I can adjust that.
See how nice and dense you can get that.
It's really cold.
Now it shouldn't be snowing on the inside,
but that's not a problem.
Now you can also change the horizon.
So you wanna enable the horizon.
Right now with the amount of fog,
you won't really see it as much,
but you can play around with that.
And finally, you can see the ocean.
You're able to make adjustments if you wanted to,
but we're not going to.
So hopping right back into our,
a bit of our PowerPoint here.
So this is everything that you just basically need to know
with playing around with your environment
to get that feel of what you're going for,
to make it more realistic.
And now as previous things talking about lighting
as well as the environment,
all of these factors will make or break your scene.
So keep those in mind while you're working.
And here's a great link that you can use
that is our documentation that we'll talk more
about the ambient settings.
And we will move right along into the final thing,
which is how to share our project.
So let's get started into that.